Speaker 1: So we're continuing our conversations
with a number of different Republicans running in
the 2022 midterm elections. Today, we're going
to be speaking with John Gibbs. John Gibbs is a
Trump endorsed Republican, the former assistant
secretary for community planning and development
at HUD in the Trump administration and is
running in Michigan's third congressional
district. The incumbent in that race is
Peter Meyer. It's great to have you on,
John. I really appreciate your time.
Speaker 2: Thanks for having me on,
David. I really appreciate it.
Speaker 1: So let's start with something really
easy just to kind of get started. Donald Trump
took a bit of issue with your opponent's last
name, having a silent Jay in it. He seemed not
to like that at a recent rally. You take no issue
with the spelling of your opponent's name, right?
Speaker 2: Well, I think the difference is I'm
from Michigan, and so we grew up seeing
the supermarket chain and whatnot.
So we're really used to it. But I can
see how someone who's not from here,
like President Trump, would not be familiar
with that spelling or how I pronounce it. So,
you know, that's how I look at it.
Speaker 1: Beautiful. Okay. So I want to start
with what is leading you to run. Most people
who choose to run say, well, to some degree,
I mean, people in media and people in politics,
in a sense, there's a narcissistic element,
right? Like, if you're in media and you want
to talk, you have to on some level think
what I'm saying is at least as interesting as
what anybody else is going to have to say. And if
you're going to run for office, to some degree,
you believe you can do a better job than the
person that's there. So tell me about that. What
problems do you see that you think you can fix?
Speaker 2: Well, I mean, the list goes on and
on. But we have an inflation which is causing
gas prices to, you know, skyrocket through the
roof. We have empty shelves at stores and you
have high prices at grocery stores as well
for basic things like chicken or pork chop,
whatever it might be. This is having a huge impact
on the middle class and working class folks,
especially the poor and minorities, really
got to step up and do something about this.
And that's just a message that doesn't talk
about Afghanistan and the botched withdrawal
and Ukraine and what's going on there. So
I think there's just a very long list of
issues that we need to address. And I think
very humbly, based on my experience in D.C.
for four years and how an administration, I got
to learn the machinery of how government works.
I was there for longer than my primary opponent
has been there. So I've got more experience than
I have in that. Also, I'm a regular guy. I'm not
from a, you know, super, super loaded background.
So I know what it's like to connect with regular
folks. So I think I've got the best of both
worlds there. But David, you do have a point.
I mean, you have people who are narcissistic
and this profession does attract those kind
of people. And I myself, after administration,
was not planning on going into politics. I was, in
fact, planning on becoming a regular person again,
you know, maybe doing some work for
a think tank or something and just,
you know, getting out of the spotlight for a
bit. But then some friends, you know, for a
said, hey, why don't you go back home to Michigan
and, you know, take a run against this Peter Meyer
guy who voted to impeach Trump. And it took me a
while. I thought about it a lot. I prayed about
it. I made sure I had my ducks in a row and
ended up diving in head first to do it. But
it's not really necessarily. I was thinking I
was kind of looking forward to being a regular
person again. So yeah, I mean, it does really
take something to drop out here and do this.
It's very busy, you know, you're going to
get attacked and there's long hours and
there's scrutiny and things. But I do really
think it's worth it because, you know, we need the
leadership in there, which is lacking right now.
Speaker 1: So you mentioned three issues there.
The first one was was inflation and
gas prices and product product prices.
That's that's something that's happening globally
right now. There's a number of issues there.
As one of 435 members of Congress in the
United States, what would you do to deal with
the issue of inflation, which is a global one?
Speaker 2: Well, it's a global issue to some
degree. But a lot of this money that's being
printed and the spending that's happening does
have global impact because the investors take that
money and they invest it all around the world.
So I do think the Europeans certainly
have their share of guilt in this for
doing some of the same stuff we're doing. But
I think when you look at the kind of spending
and the kind of money printing that's happening,
you're getting what's called the Cantillon Effect,
which is where all this money goes in to
the economy in an efficient way and ends
up driving up prices in a way that is harmful to
regular folks. So we do have to look at the money
printing and the spending, which are two of the
critical points behind this. And David, you have
a very good point. If I were to win, God willing,
I'm one of 435. So I need to form coalitions. I
need people that are on my side. I need to have a
maturity to understand that everybody that we're
in coalition with won't agree on every issue.
Speaker 1: But John, I hate to interrupt,
but I really like I love talking about policy
and we were I want to stay on that instead of
the coalition. You're talking about money
printing. Now, Joe Biden's administration
did pass this infrastructure package
and that includes government spending.
And we could debate whether it's the type of
spending that you like or that you don't like.
But the deficit declined during Joe Biden's
first year compared to Donald Trump's last
year. In other words, spending in total. The rate
at which we overspent went down in the first year
of Joe Biden's presidency. Would you would you
agree with those numbers from the Congressional
Budget Office, which is nonpartisan, not the debt?
Now, remember, I know you know the difference.
You're a Harvard guy. The deficit went
down in Joe Biden's first year. Do you
agree with those numbers? You dispute them?
Speaker 2: I'll need to check that because
I've actually heard differing views on that. So
I want to go back and look at numbers and see if
there's any fuzzy math going on there.
Speaker 1: As a general rule, do you
dispute numbers from the Congressional Budget
Office or is that a fair source in your mind?
Speaker 2: I think it's not so much fair or
not. It's a matter of there are many ways to
look at these numbers. There are different ways of
calculating deficit in terms of what you include.
What don't you include? Does it come off the
budget this year or next year or the year after?
So I think there's lots of different
ways to slice of pizza here,
and I need to look at the way they're doing that
to to make a determination on that.
Speaker 1: Would you agree that at least
the Congressional Budget Office is doing it the
same way every year? Is that at least fair? They
are consistent in how they measure the deficit.
Speaker 2: And I'll take a look at that again and
what their methodology to to
see what's the case there about.
Speaker 1: So let me ask you this then.
If you're not sure whether we can trust
the numbers of the Congressional Budget
Office, what numbers do you have as a
basis to say that the spending is out of control?
Speaker 2: Oh, we can easily look at the amount
of money in the government spending. That's a
much simpler calculation there. We can easily
look at inflation. CPI and whatnot. Those are
pretty standard in the way they're calculated. So
we have a pretty good sense of what those numbers.
Speaker 1: But I think. So let's see. But the
problem is you blamed the spending on
the inflation. So like, for example,
in this conversation, I'm agreeing with you.
Inflation has been high. We're up 100% on this
day. There's no dispute about those numbers.
You made the assertion that you believe the
inflation to some degree is because the spending
is out of control. I said typically we look at
the Congressional Budget Office for that
and they found that the deficit was down
in Joe Biden's first year of the presidency. You
said you're not sure if you trust those numbers.
And when I asked you, well, how do you know
spending is up, you said, well, because I
looked at the inflation numbers, but your first
claim was the inflation numbers you believe
are because spending was up. But now you're
saying the inflation numbers are the spending
numbers. That doesn't make sense, does it?
Speaker 2: Well, it doesn't make sense as high gas
prices that regular people cannot afford. Well,
it doesn't make sense. As I had black pastors
come to me saying, people in our congregation
cannot afford to drive to work because gas prices
are too high. Well, it doesn't make sense
as the price of a pack of chicken or beef,
whatever you're buying at the grocery store
is twice as high. That certainly doesn't make
sense. And so that's the problem we got to solve.
Speaker 1: Right. We agree gas prices are high.
But you made the assertion that it's because
of Biden's spending, whereas gas prices are up
globally. And what I'm trying to do is to is to
make that connection. But maybe maybe we're just
not not going to be able to do that. Let me ask
you a different question. Do you agree that since
the peak about two months ago, gas prices are
now down about 20%? Do you dispute those numbers?
Speaker 2: What I do know is that
gas prices are still far too high.
One of the reasons for that is, for example,
shutting down the Keystone XL pipeline
and totally gutting all efforts to
have American energy independence.
So we've got to go back and reverse those policies
so that we can be producing more of our own
supply, which will bring prices down.
Speaker 1: Okay. But so so three different
things there. You didn't answer my question.
And you also made two claims that were wrong.
So I'm going to I'm going to do my best to keep
keep up here. So do you agree? Gas prices are
down about 20% from their peak two months ago.
Speaker 2: What I agree on is that gas prices
are slightly higher than they were when Joe
Biden came in office and we got to fix this
problem and bring it back down.
Speaker 1: Do you dispute
that the gas prices are down 20%?
Speaker 2: What I dispute is that gas prices are
good. They're not good. They're still too high.
Speaker 1: Okay, that's fair.
Speaker 2: So it's five, ten, 15, 20, whatever
one might be is still too high. That's the.
Speaker 1: Polar bear. So now see, John, you.
Speaker 2: Don't really care if it's down 20%
over the past couple of months or
whatever. But what I do care about
is it's way higher than it needs to be.
Speaker 1: So you made an assertion and
I agree. See, I'm a I can very simply agree
with. You're right there. Still too high. See
how? See how I'm very simply agreeing with you.
Are you disputing just that they've come down 20%
or or do you agree that they have.
Speaker 2: I try to spend time on
the relevant questions and I look at
my policy. And the relevant issue here
is we got to bring the gas prices down.
Speaker 1: How do you know they have to
come down more if you won't even concede they're
down 20%. How do you even know what they are?
Speaker 2: I know that they're way
higher than they were when Biden got
in there. And we've got to fix that problem.
Speaker 1: Okay. So it's it's not sounding like
you're willing to, even in good faith, concede
that they're down 20%. Can you tell me why?
Speaker 2: I can tell you that I care about
high gas prices because it affects everybody,
especially those who are poor and working
class and the middle class as well.
Speaker 1: The right. I agree with you about.
I agree with you. But you seem to be unable to
agree with me on just basic facts. It's weird.
Let's move on to the next thing you said, which
was Keystone XL is responsible not having Keystone
XL. I want to make sure I know what you're saying,
John. Not having Keystone XL is responsible
for gas prices being high. Is that an accurate
assessment of what you said 2 minutes ago?
Speaker 2: I'm certainly part of the picture.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 2: We do have to increase
domestic production. That's the overall point.
Speaker 1: Did you know that Keystone XL would
not increase domestic production because
it's merely a transport method from Canada?
Speaker 2: That's right. Yes.
Okay. Stuff coming from Canada
as well. Okay. They get more supply in here.
Speaker 1: So if the Keystone XL pipeline
phase four wouldn't increase production
and you just said what we need to do
is increase production, how could it be
responsible for gas prices being high?
Speaker 2: We got to do both,
obviously. We've got to open up that
pipeline and also get more domestic production.
Speaker 1: But you first said the pipeline not
being open is responsible for high prices. What
I'm saying is, since it wouldn't lead to any more
production, how is it affecting the prices?
Speaker 2: Because we need to have more
coming in here from everywhere, whether that's
domestic production, whether it's from Canada.
Speaker 1: But it wouldn't change
how much is coming in. It would
only change how it's getting here.
Speaker 2: Yeah. And we need to
have more ways of getting it here, obviously,
because that will increase supply along with
increasing domestic production as well.
Speaker 1: But why would bringing it by
pipeline instead of truck lower the price?
Speaker 2: Because it's more efficient.
Speaker 1: I've never read that before.
Where are you getting that from?
Speaker 2: People that know about this and people
that know that when you have that pipeline open,
it's better for our for increasing
the supply as well as increasing
our own domestic production along with it.
Speaker 1: Okay. Do you have any citations
on that? Because I've never heard that.
Speaker 2: What I do have a situation
on is that gas prices are too high.
Speaker 1: And I agree. I agree. Okay. We're
I'm finding myself in a bit of a
logjam because we seem to not even
be able to agree on the kind of basic facts.
Let's try a different topic altogether and
see if maybe we can make some headway. Who's
the president of the United States right now?
Speaker 2: Joe Biden is certainly the sitting
president, but it looks like President Trump
likely won the election. Here's a couple
of facts related. One. President Trump
got more votes the second time. They got the
first time. There's no such thing in American
history of a president getting more votes
the second time and then losing it doesn't
exist. The second thing we know that's a fact
is President Trump won the bellwether counties,
and when he won a bellwether county, he won
the presidency with 100% predictability.
President Trump won those, yet still lost. Both
of those are mathematically impossible. So that
seems to indicate very strongly that there is
some irregularities in the election results.
So, you know, people are concerned about this,
rightfully so. And so we really got to the bottom
of it as well as increase our election integrity
going forward. If we don't have secure elections,
we don't have fair elections. You
don't have a democracy. So this is
a really big issue we've got to address.
Speaker 1: Right. Well, I agree with your
conclusion. We have to have secure elections.
You said that something is an impossibility.
And what you said was an impossibility is if you
get more votes the second time than the first,
historically, you win. Am I
understanding that? That assessment?
Yes, that's right. Okay. Have you ever seen things
happen for the first time in your life, John?
Speaker 2: Of course.
Speaker 1: Okay. And so
something happened for the first time in November
of 2020. Is that fair to say? We'll get to whether
it happened fairly. Don't let's not jump ahead.
But arguably, something happened for the first
time in November of 2020, which is a sitting
president, got more votes and still lost.
Fair. It was the first time that that happened.
Speaker 2: Well, there's different categories of
things that happened for the first time.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 2: I was getting into a car
accident for the first time. Okay. Well,
guess what? Other people get in the car accidents
all the time. So we know that it's something that
happens. Mm hmm. You're talking about getting more
votes the second time. You got first time. That's
something that never happens. And so that's a
different category. That's something that is
almost certainly mathematically impossible.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 2: Same category as other
things that happened for the first time.
Speaker 1: So let me give you an example of
something else. During the Trump presidency, that
happened for the first time. And then let's see
if we can agree and then extrapolate from that.
The average approval rating for
Donald Trump during his four years
was the lowest of any president in the modern
era. Would you agree with that? And this is
no matter even if you look at a right leaning
pollster like Rasmussen, which had Trump higher,
still on average, Trump's approval
was the lowest of any president in the
modern era. Can we agree on that fact?
Speaker 2: I may double check that,
but let's assume, just for argument's sake.
Speaker 1: Let's assume it's fair enough.
So my suggestion to you as a thinking man,
well-educated, everything we're talking at a
high level here, given that Trump's polling was
the lowest of any president in the modern era,
which had never, it was unprecedented low.
Isn't it also possible that you would see
an unprecedented result in the election? Is
that possible? Is it possible? Theoretically?
Speaker 2: No, it's not possible for a president
to get 20% more votes than they got the first
time and still lose. You know.
Speaker 1: But you didn't
you didn't answer the question.
Speaker 2: That got 3.5 million less votes
the second time than the first time he still
won. Okay. So you're really looking at just
pure and possibilities here.
Speaker 1: I'm not. So you're
saying that. There's lots of things that happened
for the first time during the Trump presidency.
But this one thing, Trump getting more votes
and losing that one one's not possible.
Speaker 2: That's correct. Because
said different categories of things
that happened for the first time. Wow. There's
something going on for the first time that
are plausible. There are some that are not.
Speaker 1: Why haven't any courts found any
merit to the 63 different 2020 election related
complaints that have been brought to them, many
of them Trump appointed judges? Why? Why is it.
Speaker 2: Because the Democrats have their legal
game going in a really good way? I must say, even
though what they they're working for was not good.
They had people like Marc Elias in charge of it,
and they did a good job of it. Our side was slow
to react, slow to respond and to not take this
issue seriously enough before the election.
That's just a sad fact. I wish that weren't
true. So that's answer to your question there.
Speaker 1: But if there were merit,
wouldn't a Trump appointed judge
say there's merit here? Let's proceed.
Speaker 2: Well, you know, if you look
at our side leading up to the election
when it comes to election integrity. Yeah,
well enough. That's just a sad fact of it.
Speaker 1: So how could you have been more
prepared? There was an army of hundreds of lawyers
and Trump said for six months it was going to be
rigged. How could they? How could you have been?
What could have been done? To be more prepared.
Speaker 2: And a whole lot more, you need to have
that state level. You need to have litigation.
Speaker 1: They did.
Speaker 2: Or watching. There was not
nearly enough of that going on. You know, poll
watchers need our poll challenged or signed up.
Look, in Virginia for example that Governor Young
guns election. Yeah typically in an election in
Virginia, Republicans have coverage at 20% of
the precincts as poll watchers. Okay, Governor,
you aren't going to win. Republicans had 90%
coverage at the precincts. That's a concrete
example of something that the Republicans did
that was smart and that made an impact on the
election. And what I'm saying and I'm suggesting
here is that we didn't have enough of that leading
up to the 2020 election, which is why you saw
similar results you did. And that carries over,
David, as well. So the legal issues where there
is not enough preparation, very sadly. So, yeah,
I think we've got to bring our A-game next time.
Speaker 1: Why do you think that in Arizona,
the audit that was done extended Joe Biden's lead?
Speaker 2: I had to go look at that. A lot of
these honestly simply recount of the existing
ballots, which is not do you want to go through
and do a more thorough look to see which ones are
valid and which ones are not, etc.? But that being
said, I need to go back and read the details of
that to find out exactly what happened. But yeah,
I mean, we really have got to make sure we
increase our election integrity. People are
losing faith in the system. There are people
saying they're not going to vote anymore because
of what happened. So we really have got to restore
the public's confidence in our election system.
Speaker 1: You know, the polling shows that the
American people are actually very confident in
our election systems. It's just some Trumpists
that aren't. But what indicator are you seeing
that at the national level? Americans
aren't confident? Because I just looked at
polling and Americans seem very confident.
Speaker 2: And I looked at polling that
says opposite something like over half of all
people believe that the 2020 election results
were not legitimate, even though that's
not true, even among independents,
the number I believe was over 50%. No Democrats
number was something like in the 30 to 40%
range. So there's a very, very significant number
of people that believe that, unfortunately,
there were real irregularities in the 2020
election. And that's why we've got to restore
the public's confidence in the election process.
Speaker 1: I mean, I think, you know, the that's
not true, that that's what the polling is.
In the immediate aftermath of the election,
57% of Trump voters believed that that number
has since declined dramatically. And right now,
only about 20% of overall Americans believe
that. But I think I have a different question,
which is just because of a lot of Americans
believe something, does that mean we change our
laws for that? What's your philosophy on that?
Speaker 2: Well, you know, I think you have a
point there, David, that we do what's right, not
based on popular opinion, but this is a nation
where a popular opinion does happen to be
right about where it is. And so, like I said,
the results were mathematically impossible. So
we've got to look at what happened. We've also got
to make sure elections are secure going forward.
Speaker 1: You know, it's weird because everybody
who is saying that this was a mathematical
impossibility. So I'm hearing you say it.
I don't know if you're familiar who Mike
Lindell is. He sells pillows on television.
I don't know if you've heard of him.
Speaker 2: I've heard of him, yes.
Speaker 1: Yeah. He says it's a mathematical
impossibility. Sometimes lawyers who have no
training in mathematics say it's a mathematical
impossibility. But then you go to actual
statisticians and they say there's nothing here
that raises any red flags whatsoever. Do you think
there's some reason why it's non mathematicians
that are convinced about the mathematical
impossibility? I'm trying to figure that out.
Speaker 2: Out of that, that if you ask
mathematicians, you will find that they
will say these are highly irregular numbers,
especially the two cases I cited. So I
believe that there are many who would
admit that these numbers are impossible.
Speaker 1: Hmm. Okay. When it comes to
your platform, if you were lucky enough to
win in 2022 and I know you've got to run in
a couple of minutes, so we'll kind of end on this
note. What would be your goal with regard to what
is being threatened as an impeachment of Joe
Biden if Republicans take the House and you win,
do you think that that's something that the House
of Representatives should prioritize the way
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE
and Lauren Boebert and others have said.
Speaker 2: Of the evidence, the evidence
warrants that. Absolutely. And the evidence says
the policies of the Biden administration
deliberately have hurt millions of people with
recklessness and carelessness. If we determine
that, then, yes, it would be appropriate.
Speaker 1: Do you have any specific policy right
now that you suspect might meet that threshold?
Speaker 2: I think, one, you've got to look at the
committee response, the investigation there. Two,
we've got to look at the Afghanistan
withdrawal, which got Americans killed.
And there's also the possibility of
looking at Ukraine as well and the absolute
lack of leadership that's being shown right now.
Those are some possibilities. And as we dig into
those and we find out that there are high crimes
and misdemeanors and those need to be pursued.
Speaker 1: So you're open. I know you're saying
you're not saying for sure, but you might support
impeaching Joe Biden for his response to Russia's
invasion of Ukraine. Did I hear that correctly?
Speaker 2: If there's evidence that
American weakness has led to deaths
of Americans, which is not as much an
issue in Ukraine, but more on Afghanistan
as well as on the southern border. Frankly,
the whole southern border situation,
which is human trafficking, is absolutely
outrageous. So if we investigate those and
we find out there are high crimes and
misdemeanors, then, yes, you've got a
you have a constitutional obligation to do so.
Speaker 1: So the four possible it's four possible
areas of Biden impeachment. It was covered
Afghanistan, Ukraine and the border. Is that
is it there's those four. Are there more?
Speaker 2: Perhaps there could be others. You
know, we'll take a look at it and see. And if we
find that there are high crimes and misdemeanors
and we would go to the next step.
Speaker 1: Wow. Wow. John Gibbs. John Gibbs is
running as a Republican. He's running to unseat
Congressman Peter Meyer. That's a silent Jay,
as we now all know. John, I really appreciate your
time today. It's quite an eye opening platform and
I look forward to following your campaign.
Speaker 2: Thank you, David. I really
appreciate it. Thanks for having me on.